oui
la mort en direct d'un homme noir
asphyxie fut le genou d'un police ont
une image choquante une par mi-temps dos
le nom de john floyd s'ajoute à une
longue liste d'hommes noirs tué par des
policiers comme fils enzo castil tué de
sept balles dans sa voiture en juillet
2016 minnesota en magasin terme imité en
cause un feu de freinage défectueux ou
encore mike brown a battu deux si mal
tirée par un policier en ou 2014 à
ferguson au missouri
les probabilités sont claires le risque
ou un afro-américain de se faire tuer un
policier et deux fois et demie plus
élevé que pour un blanc c'est
l'abstention a compilé étudié plus de
dix mille cas de violences policières et
à ses yeux une conclusion s'impose peut
parler de réforme dit-il
mais rien ne changera tant qu'on ne
s'attaquera pas aux problèmes centrale
beaucoup de policiers ont peur des noirs
mais les prisons secrètes
c'est une réalité
il couvre en occuper une wii hd rui da
l'autre problème c'est l'impunité car
les policiers impliqués sont rarement
inquiétés ce responsable de la mort de
filet noka style et de michael brown ont
été blanchis en cours
l'explication est simple selon la
procureure sharon fichman tout le monde
n'est pas égal devant la loi
moche jury la plupart des jurys dit ils
ne veulent pas douter de la parole de
nos officiers de police a selon lui il
faut des preuves vidéo accablante pour
espérer que justice soit faite
comme celle ci montre en ce policier qui
abat de huit balles dans le dos watch
cote 1 caroline du sud en 2015
dans ce cas l'officier a écopé de 20 ans
de prison
j'ai enquêté et mener la poursuite pour
le meurtre de one touch code dit il et
même si la vidéo était très clair le
jury voulait quand même donné à
l'officier cela que le bénéfice du doute
qui postulent once again un problème de
préjugés selon lui et pourtant des il ya
des policiers manquent aussi les
policiers montent avec impunité
c'est un secret de polichinelle
confirment les quatre agents
responsables de la mort de torchwood ne
font pas exception
impossible donc selon lui de penser
réformer la police sans changer en
profondeur la formation la mentalité la
culture des forces de l'ordre
il ya une mentalité de guerrier au sein
de la police dit il quand on est
guerrier
on a besoin d'un ennemi et les citoyens
deviennent des cibles et c'est le même
si beaucoup disent croire que la mort de
georges floyd marquera un point tournant
philippe stenson et jay fishman restent
sceptiques
109 cas il est difficile de changer les
choses
les services de police les syndicats et
toute la structure légale font en sorte
que les policiers n'ont jamais vraiment
été imputable
il faut dire que dans ce domaine aux
états unis l'histoire a tendance à se
répéter et elle donne raison aux
pessimistes